tartuffe à la comédie-française cela
peut paraître surprenant mais la pièce
n'avait plus été joué dans la maison de
molière depuis 15 ans cette nouvelle
mise en scène est un peu de lentilles
savary un décor très dépouillée et un
texte pratiquement à nu reportage
dominique poncet et marc felix mémos et
messieurs dans dix minutes dans dix
minutes le début de la représentation
dans 10 minutes merci
plus que dix minutes donc dix minutes
avant que le rideau se lève sur l'une
des plus illustres pièce de molière
tartuffe ou l'imposteur
la concentration est extrême et malgré
quelques sourires le trac presque
perceptible car pour cette mise en scène
les acteurs vont jouer dans un décor nu
aucun accessoire ne viendra distraire
l'oeil du spectateur
les comédiens vont défendre leur
personnage sans autre a fui apparent que
le rythme de l'alexandrin evora vie
selon le prendre c'est un homme qui
savez vous de quoi je suis capable
pour ce qu'il vous mon frère en
extérieur et pour tout ce qu'on voit
ne croyez-vous meilleur non c'est une
représentation tartuffe à la comédie
française
dans cette petite boîte qui recrée un
peu le le très tôt parce que molière
c'est vraiment ça avant toute chose le
très tôt selon le ciel défendent certain
contentement
mais on trouve avec lui et ça comme
devant selon divers besoins il est une
science d'étendre les liens de notre
conscience et dû rectifier le mal de
l'action avec la pureté de notre
attention on convint on va essayer d'y
trouver comment dire un écho
contemporain mais plus dans le la façon
de jouer les enjeux et là entre maj je
parle
journée moins de glace je suis fort
chatouilleuse presque à chaque réplique
de tartuffe et connu la fin et ça fout
les jetons c'est vrai mais c'est mais
c'est oui c'est extrêmement jouissif
c'est ccd scènes savoureuses 3,6
tartuffe continue à nous émouvoir
c'est qu'aujourd'hui encore trop de
voyous sans scrupules continue d'abuser
dans nos progrès dur